hallo war damals zu kommen meine lieben
freunde wir machen heute einen nicht
lachen challenge mit die gibt es
generell neben nicht so viel zu machen
ich bin total schlecht
[Musik]
ich bin so schlecht ich bin so
schlechten sommers monti wo sie sind
noch da wie arabisch
[Musik]
so kann das gar nicht
die genauen humor dieser dumme unusual -
chance
[Musik]
verstanden
[Gelächter]
ich liebe das
ist genau wohin nun wohl jeder einzelne
[Musik]
mit stift haben wir stift immerhin
stiftet er kann haben und ich kann es
auch unterschiede geben wäre
ich konnte das mal
das
ist ein affe ich hab's mal ruhig nach
hause schnell und gewesen
es ist ein esel nein das ist nicht was
das war ich dann lese ich das ist ein
esel
das ist unfug ideen immer finster
schicken
das system kann mir nicht passieren
ja ich könnte katzen wirklich essen und
agrarpolitische so eklig
[Applaus]
was was gibt's denn plötzlich mit meiner
oma ab
hast du schon mal so eine ältere frau
der rote springen sehen ich habe mich
selbst nehmen darunter springen sind das
ist auch 3 oder das 0 5 nicht vom fünfer
springe ich nicht ich bin auch nur drei
gesprungen
[Musik]
also vom 3er okay aber dass ich mal fünf
weiß leben zu retten
[Musik]
nein
weil ich jetzt die hand geben
so was hab ich mal eingesetzt
euro
du in die küche nein du in der küche
eher lustig wenn jetzt unten irgendwie
nimmt
wenn ein anderes herausgekommen wir das
war witzig gewesen was bringt hier
sollen da rauskommt
was war ihre mission die das einfach
amerikaner alles bricht auseinander wenn
man es einmal berührt
[Musik]
oh nein und die blumen
sind aber auch so deine ball links
geldsegen nicht da bist du blöd
[Musik]
b
nein schnee
[Musik]
ist ja gerne frei aus grosny das war
eine banane
oder nicht wissen was wo und so weit
oben
aber wie konnte dann hören auf audio.de
was heißt der tod
[Musik]
von welchem musik einfach mein spiel ist
die musik macht normal
[Musik]
rate von fantasien spiel ja
aber das sieht geil aus in salz streuen
das weckt ich habe keine schlangen ein
schwein das
[Musik]
eine ganz wäre auch ein schäbiges haus
also die mülltonnen haustier tiere werde
ganz ein papagei und
was machst du hier
ich wollte eine hand weg
[Musik]
trinkt sagt für zwei wochen an dem tag
wo die perfekte doch
wer so traurig es tut mir im herzen weh
ich bin ja ein riesiger eis fern ich
warte ich eben da heißt es
[Musik]
und ein online
was längst wie teuer ist so ein bohrer
aufsatz da gewesen gerade untergegangen
ist 2000 euro 12.000 euro normal ist
dass ich habe geraten jetzt zwei gesagt
ich kann mal kurz kugeln
an der stelle wo ich diese nicht lachen
stelle ich das allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat und das kann einen daumen
hoch unter diesem video her da am morgen
einen kanal und klickt auf die glocken
wie das nichts verpassen payton
ich fand es nicht so witzig ich finde
dich nicht so witzig